For me, my worst gigs were always when I first started,
because I didn't know any better.
Yeah.
People were like, do you want 50 bucks to do like a bar mitzvah? You know,
for 200 people and you think, yeah.
What 50 bucks that's the most I've ever been paid for anything. And, you know,
would you have anything from the early days of like now looking back you're
like, what was that?
Oh yeah. I mean, I took any gig.
I took a gig once upstate and it was like a five-hour drive.
It'd be in three guys, got drunk on the way up. And we get there,
it was in Minerva, New York. And it was so rural that,
that our cell phones didn't work. And it was in a biker bar. And,
uh, you know, the guy was like, all right, you just gotta fill.
It was three of us. And he's like, you gotta do an hour and a half.
And I probably had like four minutes to my name. That was good. And plus,
you know, I'm living in New York, so it's a bunch of like, I like gays,
you know, gay guys are fun and all this, you know, liberal. And, uh,
they were not having it. And you know, I'm,
I'm bombing within two minutes and I have 28 minutes to go.
I can tell they're going to hate all my material. So I'm trying to riff.
And finally they hate us, the whole thing. We're standing on a pool table,
by the way we finished the night, everybody does their half-hour.
Everybody eats and they hate us.
And we walk up to the bar and the bartender goes that wasn't enough time.
And we're like, Hey, we did at least a half hour each. And uh, he's like, well,
my, my audience wants more and I'm paying you. And I'm telling you,
you need to do more time. And the guy who got the gig was like, dude,
you don't get comedy. You know, you do an hour and a half. It's over like this.
This is it. You paid for it. We gave it to you. And that's it.
And plus we did our act. We can't go back up there. They hate us and we're done,
we're out of material. And he's like, well, you better get back up there.
And he put a gun on the bar, but a shotgun on the bar. And we were like,
that's, let's hit it, baby. Let's get back up there.
So we went back up and did more time.
Man. That's insane.
It's crazy that in a story where you're standing on a pool table,
that's one of the most Tang things.
Yeah, it was bad. It was really weird to sleep there.
When, when you got there and they were like, Hey,
you're going to have to stand on the pool table where you like,
but that's not right. I mean, or.
A little, but we were also like, Hey,
it's kind of a stain we'll make do we're faced. You know, we're at a bar,
there's a biker guys are here. Like we just kinda did whatever. He said,
these guys were terrifying and tough and leathery. And you know,
there's no cell phone service up there. I mean,
it was the whole thing was terrified, but, uh, we slept there too.
I remember we got so drunk.
We had to sleep in the back and they had some cabins and we almost got like a
fist fight with one of the guys. And it was a rough, rough gig.
What was that rest of the set? Like after you have to go back up there,
what did you even do? Oh, you know, you just go.
Hey, uh, every idea you had that could have been a bit, maybe one day,
you just threw that out there and you're just counting the seconds. Like,
please let me be done. And uh, you know, you're like, Oh, look at that.
Elk's head on the wall. Hey, elk said, that's gotta suck. Oh, you're shot.
You're hung up on a wall. And my nerve in New York. Am I write books?
I don't want to be here when I'm alive. Yeah. Antlers. What about uncle ERs?
Ah, ah, hello.
He's just trying anything comedic in any kind of joke format,
anything you got pulled out of your and uh, Bob, where are you from here?
All right. Do you ever get out of here? No. Yeah. You got any dreams? No.
And you're like, all right, well, Bob's done. We're out with Bob. You know,
that's the whole, that was the whole thing. So it was tough.
Good Lord. So,
and do you remember when you got paid for that?
I think it was, uh, I think it came out to like 25 bucks each.
So the guy probably paid 75 total. Uh,
and when we did it, we knew, we said five hours for 25 bucks. We'll take it.
I mean, it was so we were so new in the comedy that it was,
it was also an adventure like, Oh, let's go into this crazy town.
Let's get in the car, we'll get road beers.
We bought a case of beer and the car, you're listening to music.
You're with your friends, we're going to sleep. There's going to be crazy. Holy.
A biker bar. So, you know, you're, you're 23 years old or 24 years old.
So at the time it was like, this'll be, this'll be interesting.
Oh my God, that is horrendous.
It was horrendous. And you know, still we laughed about it on the ride home.
It was a long five hours to get home hung over,
but we had a fun time at the end of that. I mean, it was a story.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I guess if you can look at it, that's the thing, like,
it takes a long time to get to the point where you look at those and think,
well, at least this will be a good story because when you're in that moment,
all you're thinking is like,
I don't know if I'm going to be able to do comedy after this for me.
Do you have any, like, I feel like for me,
I've had some shows where that drive back to wherever the hotel,
the condo, your house, whatever. It's like, you're just like, what, what did I,
who did I think I was to get into this business and have any of
those shows that you're like on the edge? And you're like,
should I just be done?
Uh, I guess I never really had a lot of that because I have no plan B you know,
it was just like, all right. Uh, that was a bad night.
And I was,
I knew I was in this for the long haul that I never really had a lot of that.
Like I'm quitting, but I've had so many nights where I wanted to kill myself.
Like the, the, the,
the embarrassment and the affiliation was so bad that I'm like,
I don't know how to stop feeling like this. So I just want to kill myself.
Or you just drown yourself in a bottle of bourbon. But, uh,
one time I did a college gig and Florida Kimra,
I think it was the school was Florida Atlantic. That was the name of the school.
And I was new college days were brand new. I was excited to get it good money.
You know, it was probably like 1200 bucks. But at the time you're like,
this is the best check I'll ever get in my life. And, uh, flew down there.
I landed like eight in the morning, took a cab straight to the college,
no hotel, no nothing. So I just walked around the college for literally,
you know, nine hours just bored. I had no money. I went to the food court,
but I didn't have any money. I didn't have a credit card. I was such a piece of,
but I just walked around you. Then you see a water fountain. You're like,
Oh my God. Wow. You know, like, let's see what the gymnasium looks like. Let's,
let's walk around and look inside the classroom. It was, it was so bad.
I got there way too early. And, uh,
finally the it's time for the gig. And I go in and the ladies like,
just want to let you know, it's very diverse. And it was all black.
Like I was the only white guy in the building. And I was like, it's not diverse.
Yeah. I'm diversity. I'm a diversity here. This is a predominance.
I think it was the word you're looking for or a hundred percent or whatever it
is. So I was like, all right. So it was me and this other guy.
And he was like a cute young, like nerdy black guy. And also,
I remember the first act. It was like kind of a variety show.
And the first act was like a rap group spinning, like a towel around their head,
like jumping around. And they were like kill Whitey and all this.
And I was like, ah, geez. You know,
and the first kid went up and we're supposed to do each do a half hour.
And the first kid goes up. He was like, let me go first.
I want to get this over with we're we're trembling. And I was like, all right,
whatever, you know, it. Go nuts. And he goes up and he must've done
five, six minutes total. They handled him so bad that he like,
tried to fight with him. And he tried to fight back and poke them and jab him.
And he couldn't, they just dominated him. And he just walked off and I was like,
what the? What are you crazy? Like, I didn't know. We could do that. Like,
it blew my mind. I was just like,
I'm going to eat my for three 30 minutes and then I'll get my check.
But he just walked on. Like he had some dignity and some self-respect,
but that doesn't say that like,
cause did you have to fill his time or did you just do your 30?
I didn't have to fill his time, but it blew my mind that somebody would do that.
Like, I didn't even think it didn't even cross my mind.
It wasn't even an option that you could just walk away.
Like I thought this was your job. You got to, it's like a soldier. You got to,
you can't just run away from the army. You got to go towards him.
I didn't even think about that. It blew my mind. I'm just blown away.
And I actually, I think he went on second.
He went on second and did that that's that's right,
because that's why it blew my mind so much.
Cause I had just done a full half hour and he went on after me and was like,
this, this is crazy. You guys are nuts and I couldn't believe it.
So I go on, let me tell you my story. So I, this is years ago.
So I go on and uh,
I go up and I walk to the microphone. And before I even say something,
this guy goes, look at this. And uh,
I'm in such a New York state of mind. I go, what if I was actually gay? Jeez.
And he goes, no, no, you are. And learn. I mean,
it was so well time, it got like a huge applause break.
I had to wait for the last to die down just to, just to start again, you know?
And, uh, that was the beginning. That was like the first minute.
And then I had to just go from there and I don't think I did one bit,
it was just defense, defense, fighting back, getting heckled, fighting back,
getting heckled for a half hour straight.
My God. And then after that, so after that was your feeling, just like,
well that was a bad one. Or were you thinking like,
I feel like I even know how it was going to leave the college.
It was a Tyson fight. It was like, Oh my God.
I was like in the corner after like, Oh my God. I mean,
I got beat up like a ragdoll and I felt like a teacher in a bad
school. And like one of those movies, you know,
where I couldn't even control the class.
And that's why when that kid went on after and did six minutes, I was like,
Oh my God, why didn't I do that? Right. Because he still got paid.
Yeah. Holy Christ.
Yeah. So that, but that was one of those, like,
I dunno where I stayed that night, but I flew back the next morning.
I was just like, woo. That was what I thought that was part of it.
Like in my mind where we're kind of so lucky to do comedy that I was just like,
all right. That was a bad gig. And what's next. But you still get paid.
Yeah. You still get paid. And like you said, especially early on,
like when you start doing those colleges,
it's the most money you've ever received. Yeah.
Yes. And I was so dumb. I probably thought that was part of it. Like,
no wonder you get paid a ton, you have to eat your for an hour. Right.
And if people don't do a college show,
they don't realize that they're nine times out of 10. They're not set up. Well,
it's like during lunch in a cafeteria it's in between classes or
something. And they're like, all right. And it's usually no intro,
no ho it's like, go ahead, go.
You know?
Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
And I remember pizzas were being passed around while that was going on.
So you try to riff on the pizza and I don't think I'll eat the last slice,
but you hate that guy. Oh boy. And that none of that was flying at all. And uh,
yeah, the whole thing was horrific, but yeah, you just,
you can't say no to a college gig and I figured, Hey,
you have a bad gig every now and then. And I don't know,
it hurt my feelings and it was humiliating, but I never was like, I'm quitting.
Yeah. Would have never crossed my mind.
What did what's like your a after a bomb after a bad show, vice, like,
do you have anything to you do to cope?
Well, I used to be the guy everybody hates that has to talk about it.
And I'm like, Oh, that was so bad. That sucked that I had to like vent about it.
And I I've seen that guy since and we all go, yes, it was bad.
And I know you just want me to like, come for you right now,
but I don't want to,
so I try not to be that guy anymore because I saw a guy do it and we all hate
that guy. So I just, I just drink. Oh, that's good.
Yeah. Yeah. Big booze guy. And I walk, I'm a big Walker.
Like after that bomber,
I remember walking around the college for awhile and just hating myself and
replaying it and thinking, what can you do different?
It's it's very much like a fist fight that you lost. You know, you're just like,
Oh, if I had punched him here and I could've ducked there and all that. Uh,
so it's a lot of that.
Like maybe if I had said this or said that and just replaying it and
retracing the steps of, of hell.
It's the worst thing to do.
You're you're essentially just jerk storing yourself from
a lot of that here. Just like the whole time. You're like,
if I would've said this and it does you no good. No, it's over.
It just upsets you that you didn't say it then.
Yes. Yes. But I will say nothing will prepare you for the next one.
Like actually going through it all the way, because yeah. You'll,
you'll never learn how to deal with that. If you don't experience it,
like bill Burr is probably one of the better comics that he could handle.
Any penny, any moment. I mean, look at Philly,
they arena booed him and he handled that beautifully.
So how many hell gigs did he go through to get to that? You know?
Yeah. And widget, which kind of made it, you know, like, yes,
the deal for him that he was not to be messed with. And that he was like legit,
right?
Like as a comic doing sets and writing, that's like hitting the punching bag.
But until you go get your kicked by a crowd,
you'll never know what it's like to be in a real fight. Like,
cause you need the actual guy swinging at you. You know,
you can do the writing all day,
but you need the guys looking at your face to know when to duck.
Yeah. That's a great way to put that now. Like,
so just because time has passed, you know, you're farther along in comedy.
Sometimes you still get some shows that you don't see coming. Like for me,
some of the worst bombs are like,
when things are going really well and then all, and you're just like,
this is great. I'm so funny. This is why I got into this business.
Of course I'll be famous.
And then out of nowhere you get the left hook and it completely just knocks you
off your pedestal.
Do you have any of those where like you're riding high or you're,
you're far enough into your career where you're like,
I got this and then they pull the rug out from you?
Well, well two things, one, um,
I've had the thing where I was killing so hard and I had like great momentum.
And then I S then the lady heckled me and I said something so mean that they
turned on me.
I was at the Hartford funny bone and there was, uh, it was, you know,
it was like half full. Maybe, maybe it was probably a third full. And um,
but I'm kinda, I'm kinda coasting. Like I'm, I'm coasting well on that.
Like I don't give a. Look, it's the third full I'm at the Hartford funny bone.
It's the third show on a Saturday. I don't give a about you.
You don't give a about me. And I had that. I don't give a confidence. You know,
that w when you don't truly don't care about the show,
you're really in your best element. Yeah. You know what I mean? I was in,
you know, I wasn't having the best set of my life,
but I didn't give a and it showed, and I think it was working. So,
uh, I was kind of doing well and I was feeling good about it.
And this table in the front row kept with me. And it was a fat guy,
like a really fat, obese nerdy guy.
And it was a handicap chick with the crutches, like the two arm crutches,
you know, like, uh, some, something about Mary Guy. And,
and then like a chick who was so unattractive that you could tell this was,
this is like, as David tell, would say, this,
this team would be called the unfuckable. You know, it was like,
the bed was just a bunch of gross unattractive,
traditionally unattractive people hanging out and they had a bone to pick with
the comic. So they just kept with me.
And eventually I just snapped. I snapped because, you know, you're kind of like,
look, I'm having a decent set. The place is barely got any people in it. Uh,
just, just ride it out. Don't worry about them. But they kept,
it was like a gnat when they kept saying little things and they're on the front
row. So only I could hear it and know nobody in the back knew.
So it was one of those, you got to be like, Hey, will you shut up?
And people were like, what's he? Why is he yelling at that triple? You know?
Like, know why is he all at the fed? But whatever.
So eventually I just snapped on these people and I was like, you,
you ugly come juggling bitten, honked at, Oh, Hey, look at this.
Just show list, driving by. Hold on, look at that. I'm doing a zoom here.
This is my zoom spot. This is Colin Chamberlain.
He's a comic in Pittsburgh. There's Joe, listen, Sarah. Hey.
All right. I'll be done in one. What are we like? 20 minutes? Yeah. 10. 10.
All right. Sorry about that. So how weird is that?
It's so weird to see somebody in my neighborhood with COVID. Uh, yeah.
So I just snap on this table. I'm just like, you're all gross.
Nobody wants to you.
And it got so bad and this has never happened to me before or since,
but this guy in the back goes, Hey, lay off. And I'm like, you.
They're heckling me. And I lost it on him now. Cause I'm like, well,
you're defending that. They're the bad guys. What are you doing? And he goes,
I brought 10 people here to see you. I saw you on Conan. I was a fan.
And now I hate you. And we're all leaving. And I'm like,
what the is going on? You're you're a fan or a supposed fan.
And you brought 10 people and now you're leaving.
Cause I'm heckling someone who's heckling the guy you like. And I,
I just broke this whole thing down was like, do you see how crazy this is?
And it just got so weird and Shakespearian and tangled
that there. Now,
now 10 people are leaving and the fat guy stands up and I thought he was going
to come at me. And I was like, you, you're a Virgin. Like, I'm not a tough guy,
but I was like, I can take this guy. This guy is fat as.
And he's never been a fight in his life. I can take them. And I was ready.
I was so keyed up. So now I got 10 people leaving.
I got a fat guy in the front row, just like,
like chest to the stage or like waist to the stage,
like yelling up at me and I'm yelling down at him.
And then his dumb skank ladies are, or ugly. Horrors are yelling at me.
So I'm yelling at them. And now this guy's leaving the managers in the back,
talking to people, trying to keep them, keep them here.
And then the whole thing just went off the rails and everybody left.
Like inside of a riot.
I kind of did, but I mean, I lost it on this guy because he just kept going.
And the guy, the guy defended the fact guy, it was insane.
But I mean, I felt like so alone up there for the first time, you know,
like as Academy, you're very alone, but I felt incredibly alone.
The entire crowd turned on me. I mean, some people were just like,
this is crazy. This is fun to watch.
But now it felt like the whole crowd hated me and my back's against the wall.
And I'm the only guy yelling back at them. It was wild. It was a wild scene.
Hold still my best set at the Hartford funny book.
That's a, that is a rough club.
Yeah, it was rough. I mean, these were papered rooms, paper tickets.
Nobody wanted to see me. Nobody knew who I was except for this,
apparently this old guy with 10 friends. But yeah, it was tough.
My God. Did you, uh, did you have another one? I, I,
I didn't want to know.
I have one. I have one more, but it's kind of, I've told it before,
but I'll just, I'll I'll uh, I'll knock it out on this one. Just cause it's,
it's so on theme. But uh, I did a set at the seller once. Great set.
And this guy comes up in a business suit and he was like, Hey, uh,
that was a great set.
I was wondering why you got some edge to your home and you got some darkness.
I was wondering if you'd come to my come upstate or come a long Island and roast
a bunch of my hedge fund people. And I was like, yeah, sure. And he's like,
I'll give you five grand. I was like, Oh my God, five grand. I'll do,
I didn't even reply grant. So he's like, all right, give me your email.
We'll connect. I'm like, all right. So I got the email.
He sends me a rap sheet. Oh, hang on.
He sends me a loose, okay. Sorry. My phone rang.
He sent me a rap sheet of dirt on the, all the clients.
And this was like heavy stuff. But he kept being like being brutal, be harsh.
Don't hold back. Like they can take it whatever. And I'm like, all right.
All right. So, I mean, this was heavy stuff like this.
Guy's cheating on his wife,
this guy's addicted to blow this guy's a secretly gay or in the closet or
whatever. And I was like, Oh wow, I'm going to rip this room apart.
I guess the best dirt.
So I get the address instead of golf course, a long time. This is like,
heavy-duty rich people, Epstein chip. These are rich, rich.
Manhattanites so whatever. So I get on the train. I, uh,
I'm feeling pretty good. I got my notes. I got my piece of paper. I'm all ready.
I got my cue cards. So I show up and it's just like the, the,
the parking lot is like Ferrari femur, Lexus Maserati, you know,
Lamborghini, Porsche. It's crazy. So I'm like, wow, this is, uh,
some high end stuff here I get in there. It's it's uh,
it's like the banquet room of a golf club. And it's two white tablecloths,
like all these, the waiters and white jackets.
And they got the cloth over the arm and the metal tray and the whole thing.
And I'm like, Oh my God.
So I find the guy and it's out of a movie sitting in the back,
patio smoking a big Stokey and he's like, Oh, you're here.
He's got that Ascot going. Like, the whole thing was crazy. So it was like, Oh,
Hey. He's like, Hey, you got your stuff. This is gonna be so fun. Like,
let him have it, let it rip. Don't hold back. I was like, you got it.
So he's like, I'm going to go up to the podium. I'm going to do a few minutes,
you know, thanking everybody for coming. We'll the house cleaning.
And then you come up and do your thing and I'm going to give you a whole 45
minutes. I was like, all right, you got it. So, uh,
he does his thing. I go on and I'm pretty excited. I'm like,
I got some good stuff. He wasn't funny.
And this crowd was ready to laugh and uh, I'm going to bring the heat. So,
and he's paying me well. So, uh,
I go up there and I do the mic dude. You know,
the feedback happens just at a movie and I go up and I just go right into it.
I go, Hey, where's, where's Bob where's Bob. And it starts off very friendly.
Where am I was like Bobby, Bobby, you know, one guy gets you in a headlock,
you know, homies over here. And Bobby puts his hand up. He's all nervous.
And uh, and then at this point I realized everyone there has children with them.
Like the kids are there, not everyone,
but there was a couple of people with kids. And I was like, well, that's weird.
But yeah, you know what? I got my stuff.
I was told about the whole back here it comes. So,
and their wives are there too. So I'm like, all right, I go, Hey, Bob,
we all know you were addicted to Coke. Yeah. Everybody knows.
You're doing it at the office. You got a problem. You need rehab there.
You can't fool us. And it just silence. And he's like,
Oh no, no. You know now. And like some other guys,
like I knew you were on, you're done whatever.
And I'm like, Oh, and I th so I think he just got fired immediately,
but like two people started going at it with Bob and that got ugly.
And I was like, well, let me change it up. So I go, Hey, Hey Reggie, Hey,
Reggie, we all know you're cheating on your wife. And she was, she was there.
She was like in front of her kids.
She gets up those, the napkin Adam. He's like, no, no, honey. I swear to God.
I swear to God. I mean the whole thing's bananas. So then I go, all right, well,
let me move on again. Let's try number three, Hey, cliff Cliffy.
And Cliff's like, Oh. I mean, he's terrified now. And clips. I'm like,
Hey cliff, we all know you're gay. Just coming out already. Nobody cares.
You make home all that. And he's like, Oh my God. He's like,
don't do this to me my whole life. But all, you know, so,
so basically the whole place is in shambles. Napkins are flying up.
Tables are getting turned over. Fist fights, drinks are spilled. You know,
women are screaming, babies are crying. And uh, I go, well,
I'll just go into my act. You know? So I go into my act. I'm like, Uber's weird.
You guys ever take Uber. A banana is hard to peel. Ah,
you guys ever get a haircut, you know? And it's just silence,
just fighting and anger. And eventually the guy's doing this in the back,
like get off, get off. And then he did the, you know, so I walk off and it's,
it was horrific. Uh, I walk up and he does the thing where he's like,
what happened out there? That was awful. They hated you. Oh my God.
You know how much work I'm going to do to clean up that mess you piece of.
I'm like, you told me not to hold back.
And that was my first lesson in when they say don't hold back.
That doesn't mean it they're full of. So it's funny.
I think they know about comedy when they're booking comedy,
you know, do you ever get this? Like in a club? It's like, Hey,
could you tell him it's his birthday?
Oh yeah. Applebee's you know, I know I still get that. I still get that.
It's crazy. It's it's beyond, it's beyond,
it's beyond me. How much people don't know about comedy?
Like you would never go into a guy at, at Hamilton and be like, Hey,
tell him it's my birthday. And the guy's like, I was supposed to be Aaron Burr.
You can get outta here, you know? But, uh, but yeah, it was bad.
And I had to fight to get that check. I remember, I was like, dude,
you told me not to hold back. I did the you gave me, sorry,
hang on a fire truck. And he's like, nah, no,
that was bad. That was bad. I thought you were funny. He kept,
he was pretty mean. He was like a mean guys. I thought you were funny. What the.
If I knew that was going to happen, I would have never hired you.
I'm like you told me not to hold back.
I'm like fighting with this guy on the patio and he's like, fine here.
Get out of my sight. He gave me the check and I left. Wow. Holy.
Yeah. Pretty wild.
Out. We'll wrap up with this story here because it was, uh,
something I got to witness and it was before I moved to New York,
I was still living in Pittsburgh and I would work with you and Chris Allen at
the improv. Yes, you did it.
You did the joke about, Oh, I forgot about this
total Jews in an Uber. Right?
What's what's like what's causing all this traffic and like probably the Jews
and it got real quiet and,
and you, you started doing a little riffing on it.
And then later to find out there was a shooting at a synagogue, um,
uh, right before you Pittsburgh and a lady came up to you,
furious. Like the whole show is going well.
And sometime you have a great show and it's one person, one moment the ruins it.
And it's the audacity did that.
She would think that not only did you know about the shooting,
but knowing about it, you would try to make fun of it.
Like you very clearly just didn't hear it.
No, I know. I know. Oh, I knew about it, but I was like, I just jokes in my act.
I'm doing it. And you like tragedies.
I feel like are meant to be joked about in a way,
because it's how it makes you feel better. You got to make a laugh out of it.
You know? So I knew what I was doing, but I, I wasn't like, these people.
I was just like, Oh,
I made a Jew joke and that's awkward because of the times we're living in, uh,
if you know what I mean, you know, I wasn't,
I wasn't saying like they deserve to die or whatever.
I just made a joke about what happened. Kind of, I acknowledged what happened.
That was it. And she flipped. I forgot all about that.
Yeah. She was horrible, horrible woman.
And you know,
I guess to wrap up when you have that experience of someone coming after you,
either dark show after show, how do you, you know,
there's part of you that wants to just unload,
but you kind of gotta be a little bit reserved and lose the whole thing.
How do you go through that for you?
What is your process of like dealing with this one issue and trying to get back
to either a good evening, a good show or a second show?
I think, uh, I've been,
it's happened to me so much that I just kind of go to a happy place. And I,
I used to try to reason with them, which is the worst thing you can do,
because these are like, I guess for lack of a better term, these are Terrans,
you know, these are just like older white women who want to yell at somebody.
But, uh, I used to be like, no, no, I'm man. I'm, I'm a comedian. It's Joe,
I didn't shoot anybody. Like these are words,
we're all gonna die one day and this is crazy, you know? But uh, now I just go,
I know you're I know it's crazy that that was a mistake. I'll never do it again.
I've learned a lesson. Thanks to you. You have changed me.
Thank God you spoke up. I did with Fallon,
did I thank them for calling out my black face and, uh.
Which was pretty, pretty crazy move.
That was, that was a bummer. That was gross and weird.
Yeah. I just go in and I go, yes, ma'am you're right. You're right.
Because I just want to end the thing and then she can go back to her dumb cats
and go, ah, yeah, I showed him,
I taught a guy a lesson tonight and then she'll dialogue, but either way,
just suck it up and move on.
Yeah. Well, Mark, I appreciate doing this.
Tell people where to get your new special.
Oh yeah. Check it out on YouTube. It's called out to lunch. It's doing well,
it's free. It's up right there. And just put in Martin,
Norman or out the lunch pop right up. And uh, yeah, the people are digging in,
so, um, I'm proud of it. And um, I'm grateful for how well it's going.
And in your podcast, please plug that as well.
Podcasts is Tuesdays with stories, uh, me and Joe list who just drove by.
We do a fun pod where we actually cover all the road,
half in a, on Tuesday on the weekend. We'd come back on Monday.
Talk about it comes out on Tuesday.
So you'll hear all kinds of horrific ladies yelling at me. Yeah. Well,
thanks again for doing this. I really appreciate it.
And then it was great. Hey,
thanks for having me call and I hope to work with you again. One day,
that was a fun weekend.